Lix is a pen.
But not one of the ordinary.
Having the three-dimensional ability, it enables you to doodle in the air.
Advanced technology meets beautiful design,...
...from the sustainably aluminum body to the elegant technological core.
Every detail in Lix combines beautiful engineering and meticulous craft.
Some examples include accessories, decoration pieces, arts and crafts,...
...artistic jewelry, fashion prototypes and different forms of drawings.
You can make anything out of it within just a few seconds.
Essentially, Lix 3-D printing pen has the similar function as of 3-D printers.
It melts and cools colored plastic,...
...letting you create rigid and freestanding structures,...
...which can be formed in any imaginable shapes.
This exceptional pen is a small and smart pen that does not require paper.